what's better than DLC DLC was so much
poured into it that it feels almost like
a new game cyberpunk 2077's upcoming
expansion Phantom Liberty is currently
cooking over at CD projekt Red and even
though we don't know much about it we do
know it's doubling up on entirely with
star power by having Keanu Reeves back
as Johnny silverhand and Idris Alba
playing FIA agent Solomon Reed so it
should come as no surprise to hear that
CD projekt Red says that this expansion
has the biggest budget it has ever
allocated to post-launch content cdpr's
Merrick bugdoll first called the Spy
Thriller DLC the quote biggest ever DLC
that CD projekt Red has worked on so far
in an update on the cyberpunk 2077
subreddit Community director Martin
Morton clarified the statement and said
that Phantom Liberty is quote about the
biggest budget when it comes to the
expansion packs we've released and that
CD projekt Red will reveal more
information about out the scale of the
DLC in the future Phantom Liberty has a
high bar to climb as cdpr is a Witcher 3
expansions hearts of stone and blood and
wine have long been considered gold
standards in the space cdpr's reputation
took a major hit after cyberpunk 2077
was released in December of 2020 but
currently the game is in a much better
and healthier state after receiving
significant patches and updates and
speaking of updates let's talk about an
update on what's happening with Halo and
343 Industries a report from last week
stated that 343 would no longer work on
Halo games instead overseeing external
Partners working on the franchise this
led to the official Halo account on
Twitter putting out a public response it
read Halo and master chief are here to
stay 343 Industries will continue to
develop Halo now and in the future
including epic stories multiplayer and
more of what makes Halo gray however
it's still up to interpretation
regarding what 343 will be doing with
Halo now especially because certain
Affinity is rumored to be developing a
mysterious new mode for the FPS looking
ahead 343 has previously promised bigger
things for Halo infinite this year
including shorter seasons and regular
content updates for example season 3
Echoes within is planned to launch this
March and while we're looking into our
crystal ball at the future of Halo
content let's look a little bit deeper
at the upcoming slate of Ubisoft games
these 11 titles are rumored to be
releasing between April 2023 and March
of 2024 but keep in mind the window on
these games can change at any time or a
game could be canceled so I wouldn't
place all my bets on these just yet
these 11 games include the division
Heartland a free-to-play Survival action
game Avatar frontiers of Pandora a first
person action adventure game X defiant a
free-to-play team-based shooter
Assassin's Creed Mirage a more classic
AC experience starring basm from
Assassin's Creed Valhalla Skull and
Bones a pirate game that has been
delayed multiple times project Orlin a
game that hasn't been officially
announced but is reportedly a standalone
racer that started out as DLC for the
crew too Assassin's Creed Nexus a VR
game that is reportedly waiting for
meta's approval the division Resurgence
AAA division experience on your phone
Rainbow Six mobile AAA Rainbow Six
experience on your cellular device
Assassin's Creed Jade the AAA AC
experience on your mobile talking thing
the Assassin's Creed Netflix
collaboration another mobile AC game
that could release in time with the
forthcoming live action series on
Netflix so which of these are you most
excited for it's probably the mobile
ones I read the comments and you're all
pretty into mobile games let me know
we'll see you tomorrow
foreign